I want to briefly explain why in
this matrix vector multiply example,
it's not safe to make
the innermost loop a par four loop.
First, observe that all iterations j
write to the same location y sub i.
This situation is called a data race.
So more precisely, a data race is at
least one read and at least one write
that can happen at the same
memory location at the same time.
So let's take two iterations
j just as an example.
Let's assume that i is equal to 1.
And let's look at j equals 5 and
j equals 100.
And furthermore, suppose that y
sub 1 has the initial value of 0.
Now, suppose I start executing
the two statements simultaneously.
And let's say I evaluate
this multiplication and
this multiplication at
the same time as well.
Maybe hypothetically,
I get the values 72 and minus 100.
Now, suppose I
simultaneously read y sub 1.
Then both statements will get
the value 0 when they read y sub 1.
Now, suppose that j equals
5 executes its right first,
then y sub 1 will get the value of 72.
But in the meantime,
the j equals 100 statement is
operating with a stale value of y.
So when we do this sum, we'll get
minus 100, and when we do the right,
we'll overwrite the value of
72 instead of accumulating it.
So it's clearly an error.
Now, data race that leads to
an error is called a race condition.
So when you're designing
parallel algorithms,
you need to be careful to
avoid race conditions.
As a heuristic, it's often helpful
to avoid data races as well.
But an important point is that
a data race does not always lead
to a race condition.
You'll see some examples of
that throughout the course.